what is the universe made of scientists
have determined that normal matter the
stuff that makes up the earth the stars
and everything we can see only makes up
a small portion of the universe the rest
is made up of two mysterious components
that are shaping our universe in
profound ways much of the mass of the
universe is made up of something called
dark matter which neither reflects nor
emits light but like the matter we can
see pulls things together with gravity
in space itself seems to be permeated by
an unusual force called dark energy
which is driving things apart but the
interesting thing is we don't know yet
what dark matter is that is to say we no
ordinary matter is composed of
fundamental particles like quarks
electrons but we don't know what the
dark matter is made of we're made of
atoms atoms are the things we knew of
until about 30 or so years ago they're
just a small part of the story the two
big actors in the story are dark matter
and dark energy
based on current estimates scientists
believe that only 5% of the universe is
made up of normal matter 27% is made up
of dark matter and a whopping 68 percent
is made up of dark energy so what are
they and how do we know they exist
although we can't see dark matter we can
tell it is out there from the effect it
has on regular matter such as galaxies
and stars dark matter is matter which we
infer to exist because we see its
gravitational effect and in particular
one example is that if you look at the
rotation of galaxies and this is how the
discovery was really first made it turns
out the galaxies are rotating much
faster than they ought to be rotated at
that speed that's just fly apart if the
only thing taken together was the
gravity the matter see so the inference
is that there must be more matter than
and that's what we call dark matter we
can track where dark matter is located
through an effect called gravitational
lensing
Relativity massive bodies bent the
fabric of space-time that means they
bend the paths of light astronomers can
see this like bending in places where
there are no visible chunks of matter
such as stars it must be caused by dark
matter through these observations
scientists have found a cosmic web of
dark matter
as clubs long threads of it to spread
throughout the universe but tends to be
concentrated in aliens around galaxies
indeed it is considered to have been
integral to the formation
the large-scale structure of the
universe in our universe not in ordinary
life but in our universe gravity really
is the most important forms
for the first 10 billion years gravity
was the master builder and so it was the
gravity of dark matter that pulled
together matter into galaxies and
clusters of galaxies and eventually into
stars and solar systems like our own so
what is dark that are made of no one
knows for sure yet but there are a
number of theories and so one of the big
questions about dark matter is well
first off what is it and then secondly
you know how if at all does it interact
with normal matter it doesn't give off
light and so that must mean that it's
not made of atoms because atoms give off
light if you kick them or tickle them or
do something to them and so this dark
matter must not be made of charged
particles and we're now to the point
that we believe that it's a new form of
matter particles left over from the Big
Bang it's a new form of stable matter
that we've yet to identify
there are a number of different
experiments focused on finding dark
matter trying to catch it as it
occasionally bumps into normal matter
but none of them has been successful so
far dark matter particles might just be
created in earthly laboratories - at the
Large Hadron Collider in Switzerland
where particles smashed together near
the speed of light there is some chance
that dark matter particles will pop out
and astronomers using some of the
world's largest telescopes are observing
the cosmos with ever more precision to
learn about where Darlene is located
image through their efforts in the late
1990s that scientists learned about the
other mysterious force that is shaping
our cosmos dark energy astronomers
studying distant supernovae discovered
it accidentally by observing that the
expansion of the universe seemed to be
speeding up Michael Turner coined the
term dark energy to describe the
mysterious force that seemed to be
pushing the universe apart this could be
the most profound mystery in all of
science the fact that the universe is
speeding up hidden in Einstein's theory
of general relativity is the possibility
for very weird stuff which we now call
dark energy to have gravity than instead
of pulling things together pushes things
apart the idea that the universe could
expand or contract showed up in early
drafts of Albert Einstein's theory of
relativity but Einstein himself believed
the universe was of a fixed size to get
things to add up correctly he fudged his
equations by inserting a fixed value he
called a cosmological constant only
later when it was shown the universe was
in fact expanding that had become
apparent that his equations were right
to begin with Einsteins cosmological
constant might also end up accounting
for dark energy no one knows what dark
energy is exactly although many theories
have been postulated we know a lot about
what dark energy isn't so it's not
particles we can't break it down into
individual particles it's more like a
medium or a substance
unlike dark matter dark energy doesn't
clump up it's uniformly distributed
suggestion is that it is energy folded
into the fabric of space itself most
likely is that it's simply vacuum energy
the energy of empty space the vacuum is
not a simple state at all it's a very
very complicated state in the vacuum
particle and antiparticle pairs are
constantly appearing and disappearing
and we also think there's at least one
field what we call the Higgs field which
has a nonzero value everywhere in space
so dark energy is it's actually not
associated with matter I mean one of the
amazing things onsen taught us was that
the absolute value of energy is
meaningful because there's gravity
associated with it so even if there's no
actual particles around the universe
itself can carry energy in fact that's
expected as space expands so does the
amount of dark energy so there will be
more of it to push the universe apart
what astronomers don't know yet
is if the rate of acceleration of the
expansion will change over time if it
does that could have profound
implications is the acceleration itself
accelerating if it is then dark energy
will rip apart the universe it will rip
apart clusters of galaxies and then
galaxies and then solar systems and then
planets and then eventually us
but the dominance of dark matter and
dark energy have shifted over the
lifespan of the universe with dark
matter playing a stronger role in the
early years and dark energy gaining
traction more recently what will happen
to our universe depends on the interplay
between these two dark titans if dark
energy becomes more dominant the
universe may thin itself out of
existence in what's called the big rip
but if dark matters influence should
increase that could collapse the
universe back upon itself in a Big
Crunch and if neither force changes
dramatically space may just continue
expanding outward indefinitely for
cosmologists trying to foresee the
ultimate fate of the universe much
remains in the dark